I'm a paleontologist,
which means I have what I'm told
is every seven-year-old's dream job.
(Laughter)
But I don't spend my time digging up
the remains of dead animals.
Instead, I'm on the trail
of clues left by dinosaurs
and other extinct animals
when they were active and very much alive.
If I were to share with you
some tracking tips,
could you also become master trackers
and find these same clues?
Why not?
Fifty years ago, most paleontologists
thought that fossil footprints,
which we also call trace fossils,
were rare and unimportant.
In fact, some scientific journals actually
rejected papers on fossil footprints
without even sending them out for review.
And this was because at that time,
it was mostly all about bones.
And you can see this by just looking
at how many dinosaur skeletons there are
in museums around the world.
But sometimes these bones don't tell us
quite as much as we might think.
Take a look at your own body.
You've got one skeleton, right?
But how much could we really
learn about you
and all your day-to-day activities
just by looking at your bones alone?
Not much, perhaps.
Fossil footprints, therefore,
help us to bring these bones alive.
They are the nearest thing
we really have to motion pictures
or movies of extinct animals.
So there's a big difference between
the study of fossil footprints
or trace fossils and bones.
For example, imagine a dinosaur track site
the size of a football field
with 5,000 or maybe
even 10,000 fossil footprints.
This is direct evidence
of the activity of dozens,
possibly hundreds of dinosaurs
going about their daily activity.
Sites like this give us
dinosaur detectives
the ultimate CSI challenge.
And so it's no wonder
that the famous Sherlock Holmes once said,
“There’s no branch of detective science
so important and so much neglected
as the art of tracing footsteps.”
He understood.
He fully understood the importance
of fossil footprints
in reconstructing
the activity and behavior
of track makers
that had left the scene of the crime.
Fossil footprints bring
animals back to life, then.
Today, I'm on the trail of a T-Rex,
tomorrow I'm tracking a Stegosaurus.
The living animal can walk,
run, hop, skip, jump,
dig a burrow, excavate a nest.
Tracks will tell us the direction
an animal's going in,
whether it was small or large,
a juvenile or an adult.
Tracks of fast-moving dinosaurs
can even tell us
that they could out-sprint
Usain Bolt at 30 miles per hour.
Tracks may also tell us
if an animal was limping or injured
or whether it was traveling
alone or in a group.
Tracks, therefore played a pivotal role
in what we call the dinosaur
renaissance of recent years.
This is when dinosaurs got
a sophisticated makeover
and they were no longer regarded
as stupid, defunct failures.
Instead, they were transformed
into dynamic, athletic,
intelligent movie stars.
I've probably found and studied
a few hundred fossil footprint
sites over the years.
So let me take you on a little field trip
to one of my favorite locations,
South Korea.
Here, on the shores of South Korea,
we see these rocky steps
and each one represents a mini landscape
a hundred million years old.
If we look at this first surface,
we'll see one of those
fast-moving theropods
heading off to the north at high speed.
On the next level,
we see a series of parallel trackways
representing the dinosaurs
we call Brontosaurus.
They were probably subadults,
not fully grown,
but they were still larger
than baby elephants.
On the next level,
we see the tracks of thousands of birds.
These are only one inch long.
But they're indistinguishable
from the tracks of a modern sandpiper
or a plover on a lake shore.
Up on the next level,
we see another trackway of a giant.
This is an animal with a footprint
three feet in diameter.
It must have weighed 10 tons
and been 100 feet long.
On the next level,
we find the extraordinary trackway
of a bipedal crocodile.
These are extremely rare,
and they probably looked
like the carnivorous dinosaurs
and were just as ferocious
at 15 feet long.
Lastly, we step up one more level
and we have the tiny tracks of a lizard,
and next to it the tracks
of a heron-like bird.
This heron might have been a lizard-eater.
Well, we haven't walked
that far along the shoreline,
but we still stepped up
through 1,000 years,
represented by five
or six layers of strata.
Each surface is a mini landscape.
Each surface is a time-lapse frame
in a documentary about life
along a 100-million-year-old
Korean lakeshore.
When we go around this next headland,
we run into a group of schoolchildren
with clipboards and tape measures,
and they're busy estimating
the size and speed
of a dozen different dinosaurs
from their tracks.
Their young teacher is a paleontologist.
She studied fossil footprints
for her master's degree,
and since she graduated,
this area has become
a national natural monument.
And so above us,
we see a huge new dinosaur museum
and arching up the huge neck
of a stainless steel sauropod
or Brontosaurus,
looming over a courtyard
studded with dinosaur tracks.
This area has also been designated
the Korean Cretaceous Dinosaur Coast,
or the KCDC.
Let's take another field trip
and we'll find ourselves in Colorado.
Meet my friends Ken and Jason.
They're not paleontologists,
but they know the difference
between a bobcat track
or a coyote track if they see one.
These two lads have actually found
more fossil footprints sites
than most professional paleontologists,
and that's because they've learned
how and where to look.
As they say, just observe
and you'll see a lot.
We're looking at these
extraordinary traces.
They're very puzzling.
What are they?
They looked like they might be
digging traces.
Long story short, we figure out
that these are the traces
left by dinosaurs excavating
what are called pseudo nests.
It turns out that these
particular dinosaurs
are the ancestors of modern birds,
and they liked to show off
their prowess as nest builders
during the breeding season.
This is an extraordinary discovery
because it’s practically
a dinosaurian lover’s lane.
It's a rendezvous for dinosaurian trysts,
a rendezvous for lovebirds.
What's also interesting
is that paleontologists,
once they learned that these
particular dinosaurs
were the ancestors of modern birds,
they wrote hundreds of scientific papers
speculating, and I say speculating,
on whether they used their colored crests
and colored feathers to show off
during the breeding season.
They probably did show off.
But here at our feet,
we actually have the first
physical evidence
of dinosaur courtship.
And what's more, it tells us
that this behavior went back
for a hundred million years.
So males showing off to females
or partners showing off to one another,
it's nothing new.
My dad was actually an ornithologist
and he studied the behavior
of modern birds
during their frenzied, energetic activity
in the breeding season.
He'd be absolutely astonished
by this kind of evidence
of fossil behavior among dinosaurs.
Imagine for a minute these
little birds scratching in the sand
and how different
it would be to see a giant,
2,000-pound carnivorous dinosaur
gouging huge scoops in the substrate.
Imagine the hormonal cries
and the frenzied roars.
This seems newsworthy.
We predict that it will be more
than just another report
of a dinosaur discovery.
And sure enough,
we make the lead
on the "Nature" journal website
and we get into the monologues
of the late night talk show comedians.
(Laughter)
I'd be rich if I had a dollar
for every person
who told me that they really wish
they'd been a paleontologist
when they grew up.
I'd also do OK if I had a dollar
for every fossil footprint I found.
But knowing that the Earth's bedrock
is full of these treasures,
my motto is quite simple:
Just keep on tracking, keep on exploring.
But the real satisfaction
comes from the thrill
of knowing that I can find these sites,
that my friends and colleagues
can find these sites,
that people like you can find these sites
and that they have become valued
and protected institutions
or destinations.
It's very important that these landscapes,
these ancient landscapes are preserved
because they are actual Jurassic parks.
They are places where dinosaurs
and extinct animals lived and loved
and fought for survival.
Just as we protect sites
like Stonehenge or Pompeii
or the Grand Canyon,
we need to protect
these sites for the future.
This is what we call our geoheritage.
It is a memory,
and it's vitally important
that we preserve it
for the next seven generations
of seven-year-old dinosaur trackers.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)